ABCs of AI J is for Jupiter notebooks
Jupiter notebooks are interactive
web-based Computing environments that
allow users to create and share
documents they provide computational
resources and a development environment
in which to experiment with AI models
Jupiter notebooks can contain Live code
visualizations equations and text and
allow you to keep track of all the media
elements and output from your AI models
in one place they're especially useful
for AIML model development because they
allow you to iteratively build and
refine your models with visualized
performance metrics without having to
move around this is awesome because you
can keep working and iterating without
having to rerun everything each time A
Change Is Made plus they're free Google
provides Jupiter notebooks on Google
collab with no setup and node costs and
with a ton of helpful starting tips
check out the pin comment for a link to
use Jupiter notebooks and let us know
what other AI topics do you will know
more about on the next episode of